okay John Davis next opponents chess on
earth says I have been freelancing ooh
what do i play against John um fun
opening English please okay because
someone said please
freelancing for 18 years mostly you wait
18 years you've been doing websites wait
have you been doing websites since like
early 2000s also what does this move
I'll play the Grob
because krob krob and English the grub
English combo mmm let's play h3 it's
like a banco flipped in Reverse g3
expected because john ooh
g6 they call take open h files nice hmm
I'm trying to think what my setup would
be maybe Bishop Bishop g2 which was you
to your 38 and 20 after quitting school
big respect yeah I mean maybe that
wouldn't be a so popular decision but it
is nice to like be in control of your
career let's play Knight c3 wait so
websites speed optimization security
enhancements makeover its logo design
content writing SEO nice yeah those are
good skills to have these days and the
types of skills that you don't
necessarily need to go to school for
maybe III you three of the problem is a
box of bishop so g5y a g5 begging to be
played
I'll start kicking around the night if
not a 5e for maybe mmm the guinea for my
tea for the knight of seven let's play
d4
Eric and I should have Eric and I should
have a nice off what's a nice off who
can compliment that here that would be
the interesting hey Jatin Pandya thanks
for subbing I'm not sure if I'm not
great at like complimenting people or
insulting people I'm not sure which
would be easier just have to be honest
whose phones attached also this pawn
well attacks two things let's defend two
things Bishop g4 expected
yeah Bishop g4 couldn't move okay I
could take takings probably most logical
I'm trying not to lose upon positions
very weird I'm so tempted to to boat s
gambit
let's resist but what do I do
how to resist Bishop f4
[Music]
which met for castling takes takes
that's interesting
rook h4 came to mind but it looks kind
of awkward and I don't think it had the
threats at least with this I might want
to take wait oh there's a pawn there
okay
I forgot the pawn was hanging that
probably makes me happy though because I
can safely get out of the pin and now I
counter-attack I get ready to Castle
queenside opened e-file
you and Gauri should Simon
that would be interesting like a
kangaroo Simon where we each play we
like play the same games not sure how
that would work though not sure if
that's implemented yet it's possible to
do in real life
my queen before
yeah Gauri you your name was mentioned
good job for hearing it not sure how
good I would be of a nice off or
whatever you call it
okay so I'm attacking the pawn the pawns
backwards I am down upon but everything
developed by the h-file so it's less
attractive for black to castle I'm not
sure how luck defends this pawn or
counter attacks a queen that makes sense
the Queen doesn't have too many squares
move move back to f1 or back to a4 um
yeah I'll stay in the center
yeah Gary we should arrange some duel
match / stream could be interesting
wait till I already play you you're
asking to send another challenge I
didn't realize I played you also what
does this move it's probably a good move
to this move
things are getting spicy me five i
played purely on intuition kind of Miss
about five probably good move I really
just want to sack the Queen that's it's
becoming a bad habit let's play Queen
the Queen III aligning with the king
threatening to take hey ice Lord to kill
hi I'm new I've watched all your videos
I've watched oh your videos and love
them well thanks so much welcome to
twitch always nice to see new people I
think there's been a handful of new
people joining good to see
oh no am i gay I'm getting mated I'm
getting me then
wait what not good to see oh that's so
dirty I don't I can't even fight I've no
moves oh my gosh well the game got me
that I was even kind of I was trying to
not lose that just came out of nowhere
they're just like magic trick or
something what was that
I came felt so safe I should have boat
tents can i I was losing a queen no I
had 94
Wow of the game John David knew imposter
man I mean I wasn't so entirely focused
I thought I was focused enough aha
Strider chess the sympathy bits
I was unfortunate I mean overall John
played well like it was weird position I
should have played something more
symmetrical tried to bore him rather
than exciting I was completely oblivious
this is this is very beautiful mating
pattern like just sunlight in the bishop
ojisan ik saw that instantly now it's
one of those things like if you're
looking out for it
it can come quite quickly yeah but I
wasn't looking out for it
[Music]